Your money goals are too small. And I
will prove it to you. My name is Alexi.
I own a portfolio of companies at
acquisition.com that generates over $250
million per year in revenue. I did a
book launch 12 weeks ago that did $106
million in a weekend. And I broke a
Guinness World Record for the fastest
selling non-fiction book of all time. So
in this video, I'm going to explain how
you need to rethink your income, your
investments, [music]
and savings goals and timelines. And so
here's the problem. A lot of financial
gurus, even people on this platform,
right, and I have no no shade, right,
will tell you to save $100 a month. And
they'll tell you that if you do that
from the time you're 18 until the time
you retire at 67, you'll retire with a
million bucks at a 9% compounding rate.
And that all sounds great until you
realize that when you're 67, that $1
million is going to only be worth
$170,000. So why is that? So just $1 in
1975, right? 50 years ago, has today's
equivalent purchasing power of $62.
That's a 6x difference in 50 years. The
main reason, inflation, the dollar. They
don't make them like they used to,
right? And I'll give you a hint. It goes
up. So this measurement is conservative.
This is based on the last 50 years, not
necessarily the next next 50. And so if
that's the problem, how do we solve it?
So this is kind of the new way I think
about your goal. Let's say that you had
the goal to have a million dollars.
Obviously add or remove zeros as it
suits you, right? So some of you might
be 10 or 100 or a billion or whatever
you want. Let your heart, you know, go
wild. But let's say that you wanted a
million dollar when you retired so you
could live passively on 50,000 bucks a
year from investing it into a bond or
something that's relatively low risk.
and that $50,000 of passive income. Oh
yeah, that's only going to get you about
$8,000 worth of stuff. Tough to live on
that per year. So, let's say that you
were a little more ambitious and you
said you wanted $4 million. If that was
your goal, like it was for me, you might
want to adjust it and take into account
the inflationary reality. So, if you
want that 4 million bucks when you
retire, you probably need 24 million.
That's a big difference. Again, that's
just because you're thinking in today's
dollars, not future dollars. I want to
give you some good news. compounding is
still a thing and it still matters. You
probably just need to do more of it and
do four important things. So, think of
this as your strategy uh to mitigate
that so that you can actually get where
you want in terms of your savings, your
investment, and ultimately the freedom
that you're looking for. So, consider
this the new strategy.
So, I'll give you the quick and obvious
ones that you've probably heard, but in
a new way, and then I'll wrap up with
what I've actually done to achieve it.
Okay? So, number one is you have to
increase your income. So, a lot of
people think about this in terms of
savings. I think it's much more powerful
to think about in terms of income
because like if you're not making a lot
right now, there's not a lot of room
between zero and you. There's an
infinite amount above that. Let me put
this in real world terms. Even if you
don't think that extra thousand bucks a
month from SL, you know, flipping stuff
online or making content and just
getting some AdSense revenue or, you
know, promoting school and online
platform to help people start
communities and getting commissions from
that, it won't matter, right? If you
don't do anything with it, right? But if
you take that extra thousand bucks a
month, which might not seem like a lot
depending on where you're at, that work
might not seem worth it. Be like, "Oh,
that's a lot of hustle. I got to Uber
more. I got to Door Dash or whatever."
Right? If you invest that extra $1,000 a
month in that same equation, you get $10
million by the time you retire. This be
juicy. $1,000 today, if you're 18 years
old, is $80,000 in 50 years. So the
money that you make and spend now counts
80x. But we can't be one-sided. We also
need to realize that 80k in 50 years is
only worth $13,000 today. So, in
reality, every $1 you save today is
worth $13 when you retire. So, for me,
this makes making that extra $200 for a
gig where you do a DJ thing, right? Or
helping your buddy move or whatever is
actually a $2,600 investment. And it
makes it far more worth it for me, or at
least when I was thinking through my
savings stuff when I was starting out.
So, number one, we got to increase
income. Number two, and it kind of
naturally leads to, is that you got to
stop spending so much money. Now, on the
other hand, right, if you think the $500
belt that you wanted to splurge on
doesn't matter, just remember that it's
40 grand in 50 years, right? And in
today's dollars, it's $6,500. That $500
belt with compounding reverse back to
the present is $6,500 bucks. And so,
here's something that's even worse. A
$500 a month car payment, that's a
lease. That three-year lease is 18
grand. That 18 grand in today's dollars
when you retire is $234,000.
wild 50 years obviously and that's just
one lease. So, even if you make less, it
doesn't it doesn't mean less when you're
young. And this is the point that I
think really discourages a lot of
younger people is they're like, "I'm not
making as much money as I want. You
know, I wish I could make more." Blah
blah. They want to like they want to
flex the small amount of money that
they've got because they like, first
off, never flex when you're young
because everybody who's older has way
more money. It's just like you just have
more time to accumulate. Just you just
do. Number one, you more time
accumulate. Number two, you earn more
when you're older because you have more
skills. But the thing that really
matters that people who are older don't
have is you have time. And so the value
of the money that you make, even if it's
half as much. The difference of that
last 10 years of compounding when you
start at 18 versus starting at 28 is the
difference between a 30x 33x and an 80x.
Think about that for a second. A 33x and
an 80x in terms of that 10ear
difference. And so just because you make
half as much or a third as much as you
want to make right now, it doesn't mean
that those dollars aren't worth more to
you. And so I just I say this to
encourage you to like make the extra few
bucks here and there, spend like don't
spend as much. You know, you go out to
the club, just get the like just pregame
a little harder and and and get some get
a soda with lime. All right? Like you
don't have to go crazy with it. All
right? So number one, increase income.
Number two, stop spending as much and
then putting it in future dollars
relative to today's dollars hopefully
should soften that blow for you. The
third is try and make it and save it
faster, right? because the money you
make now versus the money you make when
you're 10 years older hits harder. So
there's obviously a time value to money.
So three quick strategies. One, set a
watermark. Invest the rest. So it's like
I need to have $5,000 in my bank
account. Everything above $5,000 I
invest. Period. Or an alternative way of
doing it is saying I have to invest
$2,000 every month no matter what. I got
to make it happen and then I'll live on
the rest. I will tell you that the
richest people I know think in terms of
the second way more than the first way.
All right? which is like I'm going to go
make that money to get that thing or to
make that investment rather than I'm
going to take it out what I got. Just
something that I've noticed. Now either
way, just pick a strategy. Now, the next
one is that [sighs]
my examples assumed $1,000 per month
didn't go up by 3% a year to adjust for
inflation and an increase in earning
power. So, you can absolutely run a
separate model for that with your own
Excel sheet or your own, you know,
whatever AI you use to run a model on
that. So, if you're like, $1,000 a
month, if I do that from 18 until I am
67, I'll have 10 million bucks. So, you
could probably hit your goal or beyond
that with just that tiny piece. Now, I
gave you I said I had uh three
strategies. I gave you two of them. I
said in uh invest the rest, right? Or
invest first and then live on the rest.
Either way works. Invest first and spend
the rest or invest the same amount every
single month and then increase it over
time. All three of those are fine.
Totally fine. And honestly, if you just
pick any of them, you'll probably like
if you're literally the type of person,
what's funny is that like I I see
entrepreneurs, I see people all the
time, like people want to know if
they're going to be successful,
watching these videos and actually
taking action 99% of the time like that
that's all that actually me like the
fact that you care enough to actually
change your behavior is the big green
flag indicator. You're going to tweak
over time, you're going to learn other
stuff, but actually doing something
about it is what will separate you from
everyone else. Let me give you the the
fourth strategy, all right? which is um
what I actually did. All right, so I'm
obviously not 67 and I have more than
$10 million. Um I made my living
expenses as small as humanly possible.
All right, so protein shakes, Chipotle,
I split a bedroom. All right, so I I
lived in a house and I had six roommates
and then within one of the rooms I split
the room like college style, like dorm
style because it was cheaper, right? And
I was never there anyways. I was working
all the time. Um, I owned a used car
that I paid I paid for outright. So, the
only thing I had was my car insurance.
That was it. Um, but the actual I had no
car payments. I haven't had car payments
in a very long time. Like, buy a used
car that's 10 years old. Um, that's in
good condition, pay 10 grand for it, and
then just like never have a car payment
again. And then I invested my money,
pause, in learning to make more money.
You want to increase your income, right?
But how do you really do that? Because
when you factor in that it's one of the
only things strong enough to break the
cycle is that you just have to make
more. So think about it like if you
spend $2,000 having someone help you
learn how to sell ideally a place with
some sort of, you know, placement
assistance. I remember for me I spent
$750 per hour for 8 hours to have a guy
who really knew how to do ads at a
higher level. Cuz remember this is a guy
who was going to charge 750, not your
buddy, right? You might be able to just
buy a Chipotle and he'll do it for you,
right? But to have somebody who actually
taught me how to run ads at a high
level. those eight hours, that tutoring,
that skill that I was able to learn from
that one-on-one tutoring made me
hundreds of millions, not just hundreds
of millions, literally. Now, let's take
the other example I had a little
further. Let's say you invest that
$2,000 in learning that skill. And that
$2,000 takes you from a $30,000 a year
income to a $90,000 year income. And
post taxes, at least in the US, that's
about $75,000 a year. Assuming you live
on, let's say, $2,500 bucks a month
because you're living lean, that's
$35,000 per year after taxes, after
expenses that you can invest on for the
rest of your life. So that $2,000 one
time gave you a permanent $35,000 per
year increase in investable income.
That is how you get the absurd returns
that can get you out of the cycle. And
so to put this in perspective, if you
did nothing else and you invested the uh
$3,000 a month roughly, that alone would
get you to $31 million in 50 years. And
that's with zero raises, zero new
skills, and zero increase in
opportunity. You literally just doing
the exact same thing for 50 years. And
so the idea here is like you want to use
compounding to your advantage. And the
way to increase how much you can invest
is to make more, spend less. And in the
short term, where you will get the
highest returns, actually over the long
term, where you get the highest returns
and the short term is in skills. But
people are so afraid of investing money
in skills. And I really want to dive
into this because I really I truly want
to help. So yes, you can absolutely
achieve financial freedom if you live
under your means. You invest the
difference into increasing your income.
And then once you have the amount that
you need to compound to your number, you
can just let the compounding work.
you'll realize quickly that you get
higher return on learning skills than
anything else. So then you put as much
as you possibly can into it. And so for
many of you haven't had that reinforcing
cycle that one time where you spent
money and you made more money back. I
was very fortunate that the first thing
I ever spent money on I made more back.
And so I got very addicted to buying
money basically trading money for skills
that I would immediately be able to make
more money and increase my income cuz it
does don't get me wrong. It's I mean in
a lot of places it's successful. It's
still a cheaper alternative to learning
realistic real world skills than like
higher education. So, if you were to
spend $100,000 on courses and coaching,
for example, or tutoring, which is how I
prefer to do it, by the way, after doing
some research, as in like look online,
like make sure people have good
reputations, make sure they have
testimonials of people like you, and
they have many, many of them. They don't
promise too much, right? I'm convinced
that your life would change far more
than $100,000 of higher education. And I
do think you can learn a lot of stuff
your own to be very clear when I was
coming up. But the thing is that like
this is me trying to provide whatever
value I can in terms of like my path is
that I was just always willing to pay
for speed, right? Speed and the time
value of money is something that I think
people just wildly underestimate, right?
Like if you can increase your income
from like you get your 5year increase in
income in one year, the difference is
the value of that learning. And I just I
don't know why people don't get this. I
think Charlie Munger and Warren Buffett
had a little moment where he was like if
people weren't wrong so much we wouldn't
be so rich and I think so I'm trying to
like I I've never really understood it
and so maybe you guys can help me
understand it. I think the big reason is
that people are afraid of spending money
and not getting anything back. I think
that's the big fear. I think another
part of it is ego saying I don't need
anyone's help. I can figure it out on my
own. And here's the reality is like you
can figure it out on your own. The
question is whether you want to figure
it out in the amount of time it would
take to figure out. like I'd rather just
have somebody who already derived
calculus to just teach me how to do it
right and the thing is is that with good
feedback you can get to your goal
significantly faster. You will always
lose until you learn then you win.
That's how winning works. But you have
to be willing to lose in order to win.
And so I have a relatively extreme
stance on this which is that I will
spend when I was coming up I lived on
basically nothing and I spent all of my
money and it it essentially meant like I
almost had no savings for like years and
years and years because all my excess
cash I just gave to people and for sure
I had people who I was like that wasn't
worth it that wasn't worth it. But I
tend to always come from the perspective
of like how can this make me better? How
could like how can I get an ROI on this?
So like do the opposite of that. And so
this is like you will make mistakes and
you will buy things that don't
immediately work. But
I think of skill acquisition
like a bridge. So let's say that you're,
you know, you're on this side and you're
sad because that's how bridges work.
You're always sad on one side and then
on this side you have dollar signs fries
which means you're happy because money
brings happiness obviously. All right.
And so and so here you're sad. Maybe
we'll cross your arms cuz you're super
sad, right? Most people will look at
this bridge and say, "Well, I bought uh
this one and I know how to do this one
already and this one. Why can't I get
across?" It's cuz you got missing links.
And so let's say you buy something else
and you get some tutoring and then it
adds this brick. Was it a waste of
money? Well, you still can't get across.
It's a waste of money. No. Just like
your arithmetic teacher wasn't a waste
of time before you learned calculus or
before you learned algebra. You need one
in order to get there. You need their
stepping stones. And so what happens is
is that you get this other one from the
sixth thing you buy and then the seventh
and then the eighth and then the ninth.
And then what happens is you say, "Oh,
this guy who taught me this ninth thing,
that guy is the truth." But the reality
is that the reason that some people get
outcomes and some people don't by going
through the same thing is the skill gaps
that exist in someone's skill set are
what create different outcomes with the
same education. And so the problem with
an inexperienced teacher, and this is
very common in the alternative education
world, is that they will accept money no
matter what. But if I were to teach you
Spanish 6 and I'm very good at Spanish,
but you've never taken Spanish 1 through
5, am I a bad Spanish teacher or are you
just not good at Spanish 1 through 5?
What should have happened is I should
have said to to buy Spanish 6, you got
to go through Spanish 1 through 5. But
the thing is is many of these
alternative education businesses only
know Spanish 6. They don't even know how
to teach Spanish 1 through 5 or they
never had before and never thought about
it because they get one out of five
people get a result. So they say, "This
is good enough. Everyone else didn't
try." And to be clear, there's
definitely people who don't try. I don't
want to say that's not true for sure,
but there are also people who do try but
just didn't have the missing links. And
so part of the process of going through
the alternative education world is
having the perspective of a collector of
skills. And as long as I see myself as
the asset, I'm always going up. And once
I have all the pieces together, guess
what follows? The dollar start walking
across the bridge and they keep going
into your pocket. There's your pocket.
There you go. And so to me, this is what
I mean when I say like invest your money
into income earning skills. If you can
trade the skill for money and you can
learn it, can you imagine something
that's more valuable? We just did the
math on like getting $3,000 a month
extra from one skill. Imagine adding 10
skills. Imagine that sales guy says,
"You know what? That $3,000 a month
extra, instead of saying I'm going to
invest that three, I'm going to spend
six my next two months of it and I'm
going to spend it on learning how to run
ads." And you know what? And so I'm
going to spend another two months on
learning how to uh do that. Like I just
always saw the money that was left over
every month as like what skills at the
store do I need to go buy and then I
would just go buy them. But one of the
big unlocks that I had in my career was
that I went to um I went to an event and
there was a guy who was there. The event
was for everybody was doing over uh 8
figures was what it what it was for. So
everybody's 10 million and up. And at
the time uh Leila and I had just started
making money. I'm talking like within
the last 12 weeks. that everything just
started taking off, right? I finally got
the last piece of connect. And so we
were doing $300 or $400,000 a month. I
can't remember, but it was almost all
take cuz it was just me, Ila, and I had
one assistant over a kitchen table. Like
that was the business. And we had just
gotten married. I was like living large.
I And when I say living large, like I
spent no money, but I just felt not poor
anymore, which was great. Um so anyways,
I go to this thing. I was like, I don't
even know if I should be here. I'm
definitely not making that. They're
like, oh no, you're going to you're
going to be way past that. I was like,
I'm glad one of us believes that. Um I
was just, you know, trying to ride this
rocket with both hands. And so anyways,
um everyone goes, you know, goes through
their presentation and the first guy who
got up, um cuz I remember he was like
busy and so he like I can't he either
wanted to go first or last, doesn't
matter. And he gets up there and he and
he starts by saying like, "So we did $35
million in revenue last year." And I was
like,
"What? $35 million?" Like I was like,
"One is dope." You [laughter] know what
I mean? like I I was 3 months into
making you know pacing higher than that
but I never actually like really had it
happen at least from an income
perspective. He he gets up there and
after he gives this whole presentation
he was in the e-commerce world. Uh
someone asked him so where you're at now
like what are you doing to invest in
your education? Like what are you doing
to invest in learning? And he said I
made a decision a long time ago that I
would have a learning budget and so
every month uh whatever percentage
you're comfortable with. He's like you
know maybe it's 1% maybe it's 5% maybe
it's 10% of my income. He said, "I force
myself to spend it, and I spend it in a
way that's testing something that I
think is cool." And so that might mean
like he's like, "I'll test a new ad
strategy knowing that it probably won't
work, but I'm willing to lose that money
to continue to experiment and stay
ahead." What's crazy is that I took I
went to that thing. I heard him. And
then for me, I was like, "Okay, well,
I'm going to go experiment with my
income." And so remember, I wasn't
spending much money and I had a lot of
income. Um, and so I took like, you
know, um 10%. So I think it was like
300,000 a month. So 10% would be 30,000.
And so I was like, I'm going to increase
our ad spend by $1,000 a day. And we
were spending like 400 at the time. So I
went from like 400 to like 1,400 a day
in ad spend. And that is when gym launch
went from 300 to 480 to 780 to a million
to 1.2 to 1.5 to 1.7 something to 2
million 2.2. That was months because as
soon as I saw that happen, it was like,
oh my god. And so part of me literally
just being willing to lose the money
unlocked my ability to spend more money
which scaled the company. And so once I
had that obviously a very reinforcing
event for me I was like where else can I
spend money like this? Like where can I
can I can I I buy access to a room? Can
I can I pay for somebody's time
oneonone? Can I can I go to the event?
Like I did everything because every time
I went I made more. And that's what I
want for you. That's really it is that
like you're going to need to make more
money than you think. It's going to take
longer than you think, but you can make
it happen significantly faster if you
learn skills that pay today. And I am
willing to pull cash from my future
forward. And even though I know that
$1,000 is worth $13,000 in 50 years, I
know that that $2,000, if it can make me
an extra $2,000 a month, will be worth
something like well, just let's just say
a lot of a lot of zeros, a lot more than
13x in 50 years. I think people don't
want to spend money on skills because
there's lots of pain on both sides. So,
it's like I have to I know what I'm
giving up. So, I'm giving up money. I am
giving a certain money away that I have
immediate utility for the hope that
after I give up even more time and
effort and go through failure to learn
this thing, I will have something that
I'm not sure of will be better that I
cannot define yet. So, it's just a lot
of uncertainty. And I will say this that
if you want to get in the entrepreneur
game, like you just got to get
comfortable with uncertainty because the
game of entrepreneurship is risk and
time. That is the game. So if you're
like where do I where do I look to find
these skills? All right. So I'm going to
just give you places. So number one is
like let's just start with with let's
let's go up the the money ladder here.
All right. So at your base level, what's
what stuff's free and only costs time?
All right. This is where you've got
school communities that are online that
are free to join. You've got, you know,
you got forums online that you can go
look through where people are, you know,
teaching each other stuff. You've got
YouTube videos like this where plenty of
people have done deep dives, master
classes, etc. Like if you want to learn
sales, like you can probably go through
my sales, I think it's like 8 hours or
something like that of just all my sales
trainings. You just go through it. It's
free. You will get more help and you
will move faster if you have someone who
can give you feedback, right? Like
effort plus feedback is the loop, right?
Because if you have feedback only from
the environment, you might take very
little action because you're so unsure.
But if you can take lots of action in an
artificial environment and get feedback,
you can go through a hundred loops
rather than one a week. You can do a 100
a day. And that's where you get so much
better so much faster. Like the reason
that I got so good at sales was because
I started selling in the early days of
Facebook ads. And so I was doing 20 plus
in-person consults per day. And I did
that for years. And so that kind of
exposure, that kind of feedback loop,
like I got good the first sales training
I actually bought and purchased. I
actually purchased from my team because
I was like, I don't know how to teach
this stuff, right? Um, and it took many
years for me to get that. And then when
I saw their teaching that I was like, I
can make a better version of this. And
then that's what got me into learning
like basically learning how to teach.
Um, but that's the first year here. The
next year is like I would say like the
call it call it, you know, $10 to
uh probably like $200 per month type
programs. Again, school um has stuff on
this. Um programs out there that are
kind of like they call them like low
ticket communities. Um these are great
cuz like communities already aggregate a
lot of the information for you. Um and
so these are places to go. They usually
have some education and some sort of
feedback mechanism and you might not be
able to get individualized feedback, but
you will be able to see people getting
feedback in the same position as you and
you'll be able to extrapolate a lot of
that information. The next is kind of
like I would say the next year is kind
of in that in that uh call it $500 to
call it $2,000 maybe $3,000. Uh this is
where you're going to like typically go
through a DIY or DIY plus uh some sort
of feedback, right?
So this is kind of like your lower level
coachingish type stuff. Um that's there.
This is the beginning of where things
become a little bit more valuable. um my
preference like when you get um like at
5K and up, you know, 5K to call it, you
know, 35K, this is where you're going to
get the vast majority of kind of your
in-depth stuff. You're going to have
some level of in person that'll
typically uh be included in something
like this. Um where you actually like
meet people. There's also going to be
some sort of education plus feedback.
And this is where honestly
this is where I I spent almost all of my
money. And so I spent up the ladder
because I wanted to get there faster.
And so I think in some ways my
impatience decreased my action threshold
enough that I was I ended up being a
high ticket buyer even though I wasn't I
didn't have high ticket money. But this
is kind of just an idea of of uh and
like these sometimes also come with like
kind of like uh communities. And I think
the big thing that really like what
helped me more than anything when I
spent this kind of money was getting
around people who were way ahead of me.
like as like I just have this
fundamental belief and maybe I can give
it to you that if another human can do
something I can do it. And so when I saw
these people that was like I don't think
they work harder than me. I don't think
they're like smarter than me from a I
mean sure there's plenty of people
smarter than me but like just like it's
not like they're doing you know advanced
calculus here like the like they might
be smarter but the work that is required
that they're doing to make more money
than me does not require superior
intellect. And so in seeing them and
like like like physically being like
these are real people, it it took a lot
of the magic away. And then I was like,
"Okay, I just got to learn more. Like I
got to figure out what these guys are
doing." And then me being around them
and me like I I made more money from
these uh experiences by serving everyone
else in the community and trying to
basically treat all of them as my
teachers. And so I'd pay my 30 grand or
whatever it is to get in. And again,
this takes time to get there, but I paid
30 grand to get in. And I would just say
like, "I'm good at sales. Let me review
your sales scripts. Let me review your
sales calls, and I'll show you like our
sales process that might help." And I
would just do that to everybody. I would
do four, five, six hours of work. And
people were like, "Dude, this is way too
much." Like, that's what I wanted the
reaction to be. I wanted people to be
like, "Dude, this is way too much. You
didn't have to do that." And I'm like,
"Of course I didn't have to do that, but
I want to learn what you have."
[laughter]
So, like, but the thing is is I always
knew that if I gave six hours, somebody
might give me one. But the thing is is
their one hour was still more val. I
already know my stuff. So 6 hours to me
is just like, okay, it's 6 hours,
whatever. But if I get one hour of that
guy's time and he could teach me one
little thing that I could use, like I
was just a collector. I was just a
little golem of of skills. I was like,
"Oo, this guy does affiliate marketing."
I was like, "I don't even know what that
is. Let me go learn about that." Right?
And that was the way that I approached
these things. And so most people are too
cheap with their time even though
they're poor. And so it's like, you
aren't making any money. I'm like, "What
else are you doing?"
Right? Like what are you doing with your
time? If you've got the time, give it to
somebody else and they'll probably give
you something back. And the thing is is
in that time they give you back, they're
going to compress a year of learning
into an hour or two, right? Like I had
years and years of sales and I was able
to dramatically improve someone's sales
process because I could just apply that
and they would get the benefit and it
was free for them. So they loved it. But
for me, when they took a year of of
AdSense training and say, "Hey, this is
how I would apply it to your business."
I was like, "Thank you. Amazing." And
then I could just skip and I could ask
those people, "Hey, of all the different
programs are out there, all the
different courses, all the different I
was like, who's got the best stuff?" and
they're like, "Oh, well, this guy's
thing is okay. This thing is a really
good imperson event. This and so they
would already sift through the mess for
me and I would just take I'd be like,
"Great. I'm going to go to that guy and
I go learn that thing." And I think as
long as you don't get disenfranchised
with an early loss or like, "Hey, you
buy something and it doesn't work out
the way you hoped it would." Like, no
one of these things will make you rich.
But consistently choosing to invest in
learning skills and giving first in
those communities and getting as much
out as you possibly can by giving more
than everyone else is how I think you'll
get whatever you want. My books are free
on my podcast so you don't have to spend
any money. Um, but if you want hardbacks
because these are meant as reference
copies, um, you can have all three of my
hardbacks uh, for free because a lot of
entrepreneurs at my book launch donated
3.6 million books and so they donated
these guys. I will match or double their
donation um of books to anybody who
wants to learn. But that's for all three
books. All right? So, if you want that
um that's my gift to you. Um so, you can
just go grab them while the supplies
last if you feel like spending dollars.
If you don't, it's fine. Go watch the
rest of my stuff. Um and the books are
for free on my podcast, so you don't
have to like spend anything. And if you
are a business owner and you're more
like I'm stuck,
I'm stuck. What do I do next? Like
that's the big skill deficiency. Um it's
probably more complex than one thing. um
or one like you know tiny tactic. It
might be a strategic thing that we have
to do. And so looking at our portfolio
companies and the companies we advise,
we basically broke it into 10 stages of
scaling uh across eight different
functions. You got product, marketing,
sales, customer service, IT, recruiting,
HR, and finance. And with each one of
these levels, there's a clear problem
and a clear way to solve it and what you
what it needs to look like to graduate
to the next level. And so, um, our
little system will take in your
information and then basically match you
to this and then give you the customized
road map for your current level. Uh,
this is free. So, it's a free gift. Um,
and if you want to have one of these
kind of more inerson experiences, you're
welcome to come out to our headquarters
and book along the thank you page
because, uh, we're really good at what
we do. Just look at the reviews online.
Um, and I want to help. So, that's that.
And uh rock and